[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sock young
very excited to be talking about
creating opportunities in Bangladesh and
worldwide we have city bin Hasaan
joining us on the show hello thank you
so much Allen for introducing me I'm
really happy to be at the show and thank
you so much for introducing our audience
from Bangladesh and worldwide and we're
really really really motivated as a
nation Bangladesh and we have a lot of
people who have a lot of capabilities to
do really well like there are lots of
friends coming over to United States
Europe and a lot of these people but the
only workplace where we currently
struggle is the opportunities that we
lack and right now we're trying to
improve on the opportunities that we
have and thank you so much for having
such a good user base like Bangladesh is
Beyond Borders and like you're sure
thank you so much I'm very pleased to be
here this is exactly why I invited you
on the show because you have such a
strong passion for wanting to help
inspire other people to their fullest
potential around the world and
especially in your home nation of
Bangladesh so this is very exciting for
us on the show so a little bit of
background on Sadiq and you guys can see
some deeds links below
he's a very aspirational freshman right
now in the Minerva schools and he is
really passionate about entrepreneurship
about education about data analytics
about policy advocacy and he's doing
work right now with students on Capitol
Hill and we're gonna break all this down
and so much more I'm very excited to
have you on the show all right so we
love starting off things with a big
history perspective on civilization here
we are we find ourselves as stewards of
Earth as humans so what's your current
take on this big history picture of
human
I think one of the biggest human factors
about human civilization is currently
about global climate change and like
global warming and how people are going
towards a more green society in
comparison so like from Minerva schools
when I'm studying where it's an
interdisciplinary platform where
students from 60 different countries
come in one Residence Hall and live in
seven different countries together so
what we're taught is that currently the
struggles that we have is not just
limited to what our capabilities are but
it's also about how our ancestors have
affected the world before we came here
so what one of the biggest challenges is
how we can tackle those problems which
are coming here like global global
climate change how the inequalities of
different places like my country or
where we come from Bangladesh like or
even in the Southeast Asia or like in
the broadest a broader scale how we can
see these inequalities of where some
people are very rich very privileged and
some people are not as privileged in in
this in this scenario so how we can
reduce these inequalities and create a
more sustainable movement towards the
sustainable development goals and create
a better playing ground for all these
people yes that's that is very huge I
like your your big history perspective
it's very driven towards wanting to have
a baseline that is increased very
quickly around the world for everyone to
have the basic needs they need plus the
ability to pursue whatever they desire
as their as their most creative
potential I like that a lot okay so and
for those that are you know are watching
from simulation we're live also two
cities audience that's watching from
Bangladesh too so this is very cool to
be able to be you know doing both at the
same time okay so let's begin unpacking
this journey for you yeah okay so you
teach us about what this is even like to
be born in a place like Bangladesh
Bangladesh is just east of India yeah
and it is a coastal yeah as well yeah
you know China coastal yeah yes
so please teach us about kind of what
the culture is like what socio economics
are
like what your upbringing was like and
how you find yourself now up to here
right so Bonnell dish is a very
progressive country right now so it was
created through liberation in 1971 so
when we're just reaching our fullest
potential or our first generation which
got to see independence so the story
goes like this
we were largely under a governance of
Indian subcontinent with Pakistan and
then we had liberated our nation in 1971
and we're reaching 50 years in 2021
so as this time go forward we see that
there has been a lot of progression
economically education wise
infrastructure wise and also through
lots of initiatives that governments
individuals and societies have taken so
I grew up in a I was born in a small
city of Bursa back in our country which
is a southern part of the city of the
entire Bangladesh and then our parents
my parents moved into the capital of
Dhaka
so in the starting it was really tough
for my family because none of our path
none of my parents were doing really
good when we first came to the capital
so some of the things that we had to go
through is that we were living in in
rented house we were trying to do good
with our lives and then slowly what
happened was like my other relatives of
my family they were already into the
Dhaka City and they were already
creating more links in their city so my
family got to know about different
opportunities through where I could grow
so I'm a single child and like growing
as a single child in such a family where
both your parents are working I think
one of the biggest challenges is that
how you sustain yourself as you grow so
I started off in in a different
localities and moving towards different
locations within the capital itself like
I was studying in one of the best
schools of my country it was called st.
Joseph's so moving forward in in a
scenario where you are competitively the
best in your previous school and going
to a competitive environment to coming
to San Francisco and Silicon Valley this
has been a very nonlinear path I'd like
to say because like nothing about coming
to a certain position
your life is always straightforward but
I think like the most important thing is
about the grid that we have a nation as
a nation like we are the first nation
who laid our lives for a language for
our culture for our wider Bangladeshi
nationalism but what we believe is in
the power of youth in the power of what
we have the potential to do in our lives
so that is one of the biggest
opportunities and biggest ambitions that
we have as a nation lot of people are a
spirit a spirit aspiring to do really
great but what most what's most
important is how we view ourselves in
the future and how we can facilitate a
youth government going forward to create
a better grandmother yeah you took us
back 50 years - yes yeah - when so you
used to be Bangladesh as mostly with
India and Pakistan and then split it's
gained independence yeah it gained
independence in 1971 71 no no it's here
and you started in this southern part of
Bangladesh and then you went up to dock
of the capital yeah and then your
parents gave you that foundation of
helping you get into st. Joseph's you
got there into the high school yeah yeah
I definitely got into the high school so
like my parents were still working I was
still in a capacity where I had to
figure things out for myself because
both parents working I had my
grandmother back home but how but Saint
Joseph gave me a very good foundation
because like being a very competitive
school - getting to get into it had a
set of peers which helped me to actually
bring out my fullest potential
because everyone was very competitive in
our country one thing is that like
everything depends on your university
admission exam so when where you get
into a good university or a good school
or a good company that becomes the brand
tag that you have as an individual
yourself sure so one one very big thing
about this is that people are very
competitive de facto because our country
is very densely populated the capital
itself has about 20 million people
living in a very small place so it's
very densely populated a lot of people
have ideas and there's a lot of
competition and the survival of the fit
concept goes very largely into this that
like only the people who are at the top
stay at the top and the others it's very
unlikely if the infrastructure doesn't
go forward that a lot of people would be
able to shine in that particular
scenario so a core in part of my growing
or a core part of my understanding is
given the opportunity for like
opportunity and capabilities that people
like me and you have we have a moral
responsibility to look upon these people
and that's why I think a major part of
my growth would point me towards going
back to my country in summer and working
for the people that's right this this
what you speak of is this beautiful
evolution of your own ethics and of so
many people's ethics like we like we'd
love to highlight where there's this
realization that if I can help others
achieve their fullest potential in and
achieve what they want to see built in
the world where you're indicating that
it can sometimes be more difficult for
people of lower middle SES to achieve
their ideas and make impact that if we
can help unleash that potential raise
that baseline up across the world and in
Bangladesh this is this is one of the
key most important things that we can be
doing okay now take us to you with your
insatiable desire for education and
entrepreneurship well how this started
you like to debate a lot you were do you
started your math club you were getting
through some of these very sometimes
people think they're difficult to get
through these struggles with applying to
schools and getting through the process
of visas but you say that if you're
passionate that you can get through it
so they teach us about this so one very
important thing is that I believe a lot
of people in the world have talent but
not a lot of people including myself do
not initially have that capability of
understanding what's the power of
perseverance is so one thing is that you
can go into like high school like middle
school and see that you're doing great
in a lot of things you are doing
debating your
playing different sports for me it was
soccer or playing or even competing in
different competitions and you're seeing
that you're doing really good and you're
able to understand what your
capabilities are but after a certain
point you're seeing that like what you
can do is limited by what you think you
can do for yourself but I believe that
passion for particular things can push
you very much forward so my story is
pretty much the same like every teenager
in Bangladesh like before like 2013
where I was in class 9 so then I met
this amazing person
my mentor like his name is Bo through
Chairman Mohammed so he told me that in
life the talent that we have as youth is
something that we need to channel for a
better country for a better goal for
something which is bigger than myself
it's not just about satisfying myself
into going to a very good business or
very good engineering university because
like that that concept is only limited
to yourself so he told me that in life
if you were to actually go forward you
need to think about what you can do for
a community yes
so then we went on to think about like
what youth the government we can create
what youth opportunities we can create
and how we can make ourselves into a
position where it inspires others to go
forward so in doing that I had to
experiment with a lot of things so I
start even when I started in class for
like I started speaking like I loved
speaking I learned that from my mother
that she used to love speaking she used
to love organizing and my dad had where
was really good in ID ID eating a lot of
things so how you can mix that ideation
and your ability to have confident
confidence in yourself into doing
something which is bigger than yourself
so that was the click and I found
debating like I had very good mentors I
would love to love to talk about my
mentor Sahib in Russia my mentor my
mentor he was one of the pushing persons
who introduced me into this world of
debating and st. joseph´s debating Club
itself it helped me see that there were
lots of pioneers in this field who loved
working who loved talking and that gave
me a
brisk into the larger debating community
and to largely see how your views
outside your school can be largely
largely influencing in developing you as
a person because when you're calm when
you're confined within a school like and
when you're in an environment where
opportunities are scarce you are not
always able to see what is beyond the
capabilities that you see in your school
so debating was that start for me and I
had to go through a lot of struggles not
being able to make it to certain certain
combinations like one essential
competition in my growth was probably
the Asian world schools debating
accommodation which happened in 2013
which I wasn't able to go to because of
financial issues or because of financial
in capabilities or because of in
capabilities as a person as a debater so
when you are just starting of doing so
good like that initial hit of a
beginner's luck one thing that pulls you
down is the fact that you do not have
the persistence to keep on doing that to
improve yourself so that initial
heartbreak helped me gather myself up
with the help of the mentors that I had
and to grow myself up to become someone
who does not accept failure as an answer
but I just love to learn from those
failures in order to go forward so
that's a very big part of the start
where I have yeah I love how you
highlight perseverance is something
that's super important for you that you
had these stimuli of mentors the debate
you falling in love with the bay this is
so important that pairing together
students with opportunities providing
more opportunities for students to be
able to see themselves as you had with
your mom and dad being able to see how
you wanted to build something that
impacted something greater than you that
if every single one of us could find
that within ourselves to impact
something greater than than ourselves to
leave the world better than when we
entered it that can create a very
powerful powerful cycle okay now you
know you started hinting at you know
debate you also built out the math club
yeah at st. Joseph's yeah yes so then
there's that there's you know you're
talking about soccer as well we have
some awesome
you know images also that that that
showcase some of this work that you that
you were doing and your start and so
then you find yourself getting more and
more into competitions as well and you
know sometimes we do go through these
ups and downs and to be able to
persevere like you said through those
downs and collect ourselves and get
these these beginners lux that keep
opening more doors for us it's so so
important so tell us about kind of that
flow for you as you found yourself
getting more and more involved with
these strokes of luck and persevering
alright so first off like my biggest
stick was I used to love playing and
seeing football since I was get like I
started playing in my locality like in
stars back in 2008 at the initial stage
I was just seeing how people play on
FIFA play on like go go on and play
different things in their particular
particular locality is playing with
different people but one thing that
happened is that every person aspires to
become something in their life right
like some people aspire to become an
astronaut some people inspire to become
a doctor some people aspire to become
world changes for me it was being
playing on the field playing on the
field playing for Bangladesh some day
probably so one thing that happened is
that like play like I play I used to go
to school at 8 but I used to go to the
field at 7 a.m. no matter if there were
earthquakes no matter if there were like
civil outbreaks no matter if there was a
storm we used to play football we used
to play soccer so from there I saw that
I learned about leadership I learned
about how different people in a society
like how they can act in a team play
what they love to play and actually like
do something great together it's not
just an art about kicking a ball but
it's the art of doing something you love
doing like the art of doing something
beautiful so a large part of my life was
on the football field and I learned a
lot about life on the football field
likewise yeah yeah and moving forward
one thing is that just in a particular
competition which you have done for like
probably 20
50 debating competitions you wouldn't
probably learn a lot of things related
to physicality you wouldn't learn a lot
of a lot of things about how people
interact when they're under pressure and
unless you have lots of years of
experience but how I complimented these
is that whenever I was at a stencil like
I was struck with chronic jaundice in
2015 for which I had to leave football
temporarily so whenever I was hit with
something I moved on to the other thing
I moved on to the other thing thinking
that like there can be more things that
I could do I started off with playing
football but then I saw that like at one
point I have to stop then I switched
debating like which helped me go on to
where my coach Street John who was also
my classmate and he helped me build
myself into a better debater and go into
the national camp twice in a single year
in 2016 so that particular year was very
big in my up growth because whenever I
saw that like switching between football
debating and mathematics the three
things that I really loved to do so when
I got stuck in debating I did not be
stuck in a sadness about why I couldn't
make that happen I would just switch
into doing something that could spend my
time because I'm like that person who
loves motion like I really love not
standing still somewhere but I really
love moving into different locations so
that I can try different things no
matter what the outcome I'd want to give
it a try because I believe that in life
the only word that you shouldn't have in
your life is the word regret because we
always regret about what we do not
accomplished in life we always regret
about not doing something because some
other people might be saying different
things about us but I believe that what
is most crucial about our lives is that
we need to take that extra risk so that
we can go forward so if you see this
picture this was the first time we had
won a very big business competition in
Bangladesh it was called SEMA business
with so what happened is that we didn't
even have a team like three days before
the competition but I called my friend
like that like we could actually win
this like and it was very ambitious
because there were 600 people and like
so many people and there was only six
teams going forward into the finals how
was a team
no experience beforehand ever gonna make
it or even or that's just even gonna win
it so we made a team we thought why not
do it because the point in time when
you're most strong is the point in time
when you have nothing to lose we had
absolutely nothing to lose we were not
even thinking about winning we were just
that making the this exam so one funny
thing about this stick is that our team
was named after a friend the team's name
was Thor Han Potter so he was a friend
of mine and we just went there to like
basically post some things like just
like just let it happen like we were
just there on a regular Friday a Friday
is a holiday in Bangladesh so just going
there on a Friday and just sitting with
your friends and casually giving the
example so having a 60 60 minutes were a
written exam we did it in 40 minutes and
we closed it and we had nine or ten
answers which weren't answered so I was
just looking into what might be the
guessing scenario over here like let's
guess a 9 or 10 of these answers and
surprisingly the intuition worked for us
we got 9 out of those 10 guest answers
work and we were the first team emerging
over that and thankfully due to my
friends we had the ability to win this
competition in the end so that was one
of the biggest moments of my life my
life at the beginning phase back in 2016
when I had to had to eventually shift
from debating because that was the time
for our college applications to United
States and different places so if we
move forward from this image like we'd
see like what happened for it so quick
on the way just so interesting how one
of the key ways for someone to also
become find themselves finding
themselves at their full creative
potential is diversifying their
interests yeah so when you have
mathematics and debate and football as
you know three things that you're super
passionate about that when you hit these
walls you break through them by by kind
of oscillating to another one of your
passions and hyper focusing and building
going through the walls I really think
that's a crucial key it also builds a
mental model that is across fields as
well which is really great because you
can learn different things across those
three principles and that's great that
in
you you doing this is also very
important like taking the risk of going
into competition State and only being
able to challenge yourself and challenge
the friends and colleagues that you have
so yeah so this is another one yeah so
this this guy is one of the most
brilliant juniors I've ever met
shout out to him his name is azaireyah
so this was about quanta 2016 which
happened in 20th of November in 2016 so
one funny recollection if I would want
to share about this is that we have a
team of four going there and like
October is the month where you have to
apply for your United States college
applications right so I had just applied
to my early decision in October 2016 and
moving forward like we had our final
examinations coming up the thing which
decides whether I'm going to graduate or
not so one important part about is that
we had a team and our team was consisted
of all my classmates and we were
supposed to go there on 17th November to
India flying over to India in Lucknow
which would be this my second time
abroad only my second time and I was
very excited for this because we had a
very jam-packed team we had a very
strong team so the exams were on 20th
November and 20 onwards and those were
the most crucial exams the maths and
physical examination but I just had to
go off this risk because like this
competition started on the 16 and ended
on the 22nd and I knew that if I could
break it here then that would have been
a very solid point for me going forward
yes so I talked to my principal I talked
to my teacher his name was Prince sir I
am really grateful to him for giving us
this opportunity and sticking by us when
we were in a position where we found no
one else who could help us in this so
what suddenly happened is all of my
friends had to drop out from the team
because they had to focus on their
studies but I was sure that like we had
to take this risk because without the
risk I'm still being the person who
anyone else could become why would I not
go onto that journey which my mentor in
2010 taught me why not be bigger than
yourself so I found a new team within a
week with four more people who I didn't
even see a week ago
we go there we fly off to India with
brinster we were sitting there in the
mat this squeeze about is about the math
quiz over there
so we sit there in the exam hall Mirim
we were giving this exam and both of us
did not have that intuition back then
about what higher calculus might look
like
like the differential equations of like
multiple degrees how you can solve them
so we were giving the exam we were doing
really good and we were hopeful about
going to the final stage rate so one
thing that happened is that they call 12
preliminary teams and we were not one of
them both of us were shaking we were
like having a thought that we took such
a big risk our final exams was on the
door we risk them and we are now going
to have a more difficult set of
examination papers which we will have to
tackle back when we go home and all this
for nothing what what were we doing but
suddenly the lock favored us at that
point and we got called to the second
round around a second round of the quiz
and suddenly we were finding ourselves
to be in shape we gave that was the
point both of us broke into a scenario
where we had nothing to lose and we were
back into that Seema phase like we were
back into that phase where we just felt
that this is the moment we can win it
all or we weren't afraid of any
competition there were like national
teams from Brazil there were national
teams from 30 other countries there was
no Jordan national team the probably the
United States national team as well but
we were not even representing a broader
population but we were representing st.
Joseph over there we were representing a
part of our nation which was the only
team of that of our country over there
so two of us on the stage with 11 other
champions of their district and now
we're sitting and we're not even looking
at our combination we're actually
focusing on our things so at that point
where you lose yourself completely here
you're answering a for America B for
Bangladesh like you a choose your
options and finally when the final round
is coming there was the cliffhanger so
there is this team from Germany who
practiced particularly for this
competition so they were champions for
three straight years and they already
wanted because they they were like
saying answers in four or three seconds
which was inhuman from any human
standard they were just practicing so
good so we were at a standstill three
point the three teams were at a tie and
at that point I felt that now we have to
take a risk because no one remembers who
comes
third no one remembers who comes for it
but we have to beat that team which
takes a risk in going forward so I said
to a ramp we were thinking that the
option C might be an answer so if
eventually at a point we were thinking
like can it be C Iran says that yeah it
might be C like it might be that answer
so I hit the buzzer I say it might be C
for Canada and eventually we win and
that was the breaking point that I had
in going forward to my education and to
all the experiences that I've had I had
already established Joseph in math club
I had already established all those
things back in my country but I was
needing this break so much that you have
to do something internationally or even
recognize that you are at an
international level right yeah because
feeling that you're very good at your
country and feeling good internationally
or globally gives you this sense that
like you are a global citizen and you
have the capability to compete as a
global individual so winning quanta 2016
was a very big push in both meet mine
and in terms life because I came off to
Minerva schools which was the best
decision of my life and Aaron went on to
win multiple international physics
Olympian medals that he has he has
already solved the first perfect
solution in the ipho of 2018 and he has
been doing so good I have been doing I'm
somewhat okay
probably by standards that I had like no
I didn't even imagine that I would be
off to such a place talking to you over
here right now like five years down the
line this is an tremendous opportunity
for me I think yeah I love it
city this is such an interesting story
to me it's fascinating because the more
that we see these similarities in an
aspirational youth the more that we can
help other youth that are coming through
take these risks
you had your exams you knew that
everyone's studying for their exams but
you could go and compete at a really
high level international competition
that would then teach you so much more
than just what people were preparing for
the exam did and it's recognizing these
moments these risks that we can take in
our youthful years that push us to not
only being the
in our local community but then being
the best in our country than being
competing act then the mat at the
international level you surround
yourself with people that are equally
and even smarter than you are and that's
really pushing yourself to the next
level over and over again I like that so
much and that's a reoccurring theme that
I think is so I'm so important to
highlight all right so now you find
yourself in kind of a more like you know
you Minerva schools is one of the best
decisions yet that you made in your life
and it's an incredible place for for
young people to be able to see different
places in the world surround there's
different cultures different powerful
leaders and academic courses this is a
very contemplative photo of you so teach
us about this and see just about these
next couple steps right so one important
part of my life is that um I had applied
to a lot of schools and I eventually got
to some great ones with great great
scholarships like I got into Clark I got
into Bard College like economic slavery
Kannamma color ship which was very
prestigious like so many things in 2017
it felt really great I was living the
dream right
like like moving forward you go and see
that all your dreams are coming true but
one eventual thing was that there were
lots of things going on I was absolutely
burned out there were like from the
police I come from like our surroundings
like even the closest of your friends
happened to find a way to tell you that
like it might not be in the best
interest of you in going or like not
inspirational as well so finding
yourself in an environment which is not
inspirational which doesn't help you
into identifying what you can be in your
fullest potential brings you out a lot
if you were to struggle in your own path
right so like if you are doing something
which you really love doing and there
aren't a lot of people who share the
same light or who do not inspire you
there is a point where you burn yourself
out so at that point I realized in 2017
that this is a point where due to a lot
of factors that I need to take a break
at April 2014 I got this decision that I
was able to go to a lot of places but I
chose not to I chose not to because I
thought that I needed a break from this
life I need
break from everything basically I need
to have some time on my own where I
could focus on like myself and I could
focus on like my family and I focus on
developing more skills then I playing
again because if I could do it this time
I could do it again so the most toughest
point of my life was back from May 2017
to August and eventually through June
2018 I'll tell you why
so in those years like most of my
friends like my best friend yeah is
currently studying in Vanderbilt so we
had done everything together and it was
a very sad moment for me to see him go
because I wanted to board on that flight
together with him because we shared this
dream for so long that we are applying
everywhere likes no one there is no
information symmetry of like applying to
these universities right before you
actually go forward into applying to
different places you do not have that
information as to like how to apply to
different universities when you actually
actually start applying so we figured
that all out I am giving a huge shout
out to banishes Beyond Borders for
giving us that platform to actually see
what are the opportunities that we have
there are a lot of colleges that you can
actually apply to but you do not have
the financial capability or the
financial aid that can help come in your
broad right so I would love to shout out
to Rashad bhai I'd love to shout out the
suratha poo I'd love to shout out to in
the cup I and all those people who
helped push this idea and find him by
especially pushing this idea as to like
how you can actually go forward into
understanding that no matter where
you're coming from you can always make a
positive push in your life
I would I would just like to tell like
all the students watching right now that
if I could have made it if Alan could
have made it you definitely can make a
make it and that's a solid story that's
a solid content so moving forward like
when we like you've been listing all of
these things that that you have to do in
order for these strokes of luck to
continue happening for these doors to
keep opening the perseverance that has
to happen the ability to reconcile your
sadnesses and miseries when things don't
go your right way and you have to keep
going and not turn around and
go back with your tail between your legs
you get taking the risks that's a seeing
you and hearing you talk about it is
making me so excited thinking about how
many more people like this around the
world we can see just blossom like a
flower as we help make sure that the
right opportunities are presented to
them yeah this is very exciting to me
all right so I'll go a bit more about
this story so like just before like the
image that was there like about my this
thing so like in after like my meaning
Fiasco of like my parents had gone
through a car accident like during that
time period in 2017 from like in me or
like June my everything was going wrong
like everyone was going abroad I was
thinking that I might not make it
because I all I had prepared was for
going abroad but I hadn't done a lot of
things to get into any engineering
university partly because I was not very
motivated into studying that right yeah
so one thing that happened is that I
talked a lot of friends I I went about
30 to 40 kilometers to different
people's house asking for advice as to
what to do people who had already made
it big in their lives like I went like I
remember I was coaching for this
business Institute in my country and I
just after the coaching I took a bike
and like I went very far off like 20
like it's absolutely the farthest corner
of our city of our capital iturra I went
over there just to talk to like in the
cup I to talk about how like I could
make an impact about all this so he fine
him hi
all of these people told me that no
matter what there is hope there is hope
they had like these are the few people
you know like in life you wouldn't
always find the most important people
like you wouldn't find enormous coming
to you and telling you that like this
are the things that you need to do you
need to figure that out for yourself but
finding the right people in your life
that is the most important thing the
people who would tell you who'd stick by
you and tell you that this is possible I
think that was the crucial point in my
life where in harness I called my my
like my brother and he told me
especially along with Nafees why he who
was another big big factor in me growing
up he was the person who told me
before my Minerva exam in Minerva before
even joining whenever you have to give
an exam before coming to Minerva because
they test you if you are able to assess
their they first assess you as if you
are really good in the instant moment
they just take a part of your life and
they assess if you're doing good in that
particular point in time and that's how
they assess the very selective students
that they take in the university so
before the exam I was having this
conversation with my nephew my brother
Nafis and he told me that like this is
just another exam just another day at
the exam so this amount of consolidation
like as to this is just another day at
the office that helped me push and that
told me that I could actually make it I
gave my exam on August and I got in
September but the largest point was now
what now comes the factor about the visa
examination so why was this a problem so
a lot of students come in to come into
Bangladesh get into different places but
a significant portion of them get
rejected of the United States visa
because I this is probably because their
inability to convince that they can
actually do good here they can sustain
themselves here and they can actually do
better it meant to the world but I think
this pushed me further into even after
securing such a good future or even
after securing a place where you can
grow up on yourself right now in San
Francisco like in Silicon Valley which
is one of the biggest incubating areas
of the world I still went on to give
those a business examinations I still
went on to take that risk I even got
into them but after getting into them I
took this decision as to not studying
there why because I believed that I
would eventually be able to come to
Minerva I would be eventually able to
secure my dreams but there was a huge
risk factor because if my visa got
rejected I would be two years behind or
even one-and-a-half years behind my
friends who were already there and to
hears behind behind my best friends who
already came to us in 2017 so taking
that risk
I'm a formed a bycicle team where we
used to bike 30 to 40 kilometres every
day I made new friends and I played
finish 24 games with my father on the
police station like having that family
time which I didn't have the time before
like I didn't have that closure with my
dad I didn't have that ability to like
interact with myself in
giving spiritual time to my spouse and
to grow as an individual so I think that
moment where you see here the image on
the bottom is that it's very scarce like
nothing is there it's very shallow but
when you look up there's so much
enlightenment when you can look up to
this so this gives me a more better push
towards going to a future and I believe
that if I were to come here in September
2017 I wouldn't have done such a good
job I would have probably settle for
mediocrity oh that's right you wanna I I
wouldn't have thought about membership
rights correct yeah the same thing comes
up for us a lot too when we're thinking
about oh why isn't this opportunity
ready for me now well there's a maybe a
reason why that is showing up for you
later in life
I like how you indicate the people from
around the world when we think about
this sometimes it's difficult to wrap
our minds around into what it's like to
live somewhere where when we sell our
time for money that we can only earn the
thing that we want in a period of maybe
a year or two years versus somewhere
else in the world economically you can
sell your time for where you can get
that thing in a month or two months of
working so there's just a huge
difference in terms of passing your time
in different areas that are more or less
economically developed let's say and
what that means so if you do something
like if you do take something like this
example of you persevering through the
visa and helping other people inspiring
them to persevere through the visa
issues and getting through all the
applications to the different
organizations now I want to you know
let's keep going you go through minerva
school you find yourself now pursuing
your passions droom the nervous school
finding really good opportunities and
then you end up also collaborating with
NASA on the students on Capitol Hill
keep your keep going with this this is a
nice thing so finally one surprising
thing happens like I go like my parents
gives me about 200 Bangladeshi taka to
take a photo for the United States visa
I take the risk I take those that money
and eat a burger instead and submit a
demo photo of myself like I took a
bigger picture of myself through a phone
like and I then submit it and I was
thinking it was fine because my friends
told me that he got the visa the same
way so like that happened to be a minor
Fault in Mayan and I think I'm really
sorry you shouldn't be as you shouldn't
take risk like this you need to take
calculated risks so what happened is
that they approved my visa but they said
that you need to submit a picture and
that was a scary moment because like
even if you're approved anything might
go wrong right so I got I went into my
interview one day after our annual Eid
celebration and then we went on to
seeing that like ten days later I get
the reason finally everything said
finally after our weight of after quante
happening after a weight of nearly two
years in July 2018 I get to know that
I'm going towards my dream right
so this long wait is like that long walk
to freedom but this is the point where
you shouldn't give up because I was so
so so near to giving up every dream that
I had yes and I told myself and that is
the point that you being stubborn is
very necessary that is the point where
it's very necessary that you need to be
stubborn in your capabilities right so
so one thing that happened is that I
told myself that this can happen I told
my friends that this could happen and
even the most essential people in my
life we're starting to having a doubt
about like whether I eventually make it
but that's also a good test that that's
all that it says because like in the end
like no matter how many people you trust
no matter how many people you love in
the end you need to love yourself love
yourself love yourself yourself yourself
and finally I'm here in Minerva schools
yes so that was a short point of my
journey but the most important thing
that I'd like to highlight in today
would be crossroads college consulting
like something that we have got enough
and one motto that we have is to create
accessible education for people in
Bangladesh and worldwide because I
believe that these opportunities that
come for people come through the
opportunities that they can find for
ourselves we had a dinner with our CEO
Ben Nelson like a few days ago and he
told us one very important thing that in
life you'd have every opportunity that
comes in your way from now on
after we came to Minerva but what before
what are those five significant ways
that you make yourself you gave those
sad exams you give those IELTS exam
you prove yourself academically you
prove yourself economically and you
prove yourself socially to secure this
dream so it's not just a give-and-take
process like as to like you do something
and it happens directly there because
there are so many variables going on so
many counting variables going on and you
need to choose a lot of things that you
need to do in order to come here so
after coming to Minerva it has been a
tough time like I'd be very honest with
you education like no matter how
interesting freshman year it looks it's
not at all easy right so I believe that
in order for you to sustain yourself in
a competitive environment you need to
have a very strong sense of meditation
you need to have a very strong sense of
what you want to do so coming here the
first 10 days were fine the academics
were fine and but eventually at a point
it hit me like I was not being able to
cope up because I was already coming
from a gap here the academics were
really really cruising because it's
designed to be very very very condensed
because we are one of the most selective
universities but even beyond that one
thing is that our pedagogy and our
academics is set in a way that we'd have
to spend nearly 40 hours per week just
studying of what we study yeah so like
the the tensions really to this made me
cry at deep nights like at late hour of
the night I was still thinking about
what I could have done right so many
stuff going on like missing family going
through that nostalgic burst because you
in you delve yourself so much into your
country you're delved so much into the
family relationships but suddenly all of
these feel blank and I'll tell you this
interesting story I also booked my
flight back to my country back in
October but I had this chat with my dad
where he told me that you have come this
far and millions of students of
Bangladesh want to come in your position
so why are you not seizing your
opportunity why are you not seizing the
day why why are you just doing that you
should be able to go onto that ability
to actually go forward with your life
you should not stick that this is not
the base you have the capability to do
more and then NASA space apps hackathon
happens so if we were to move it yeah
yeah that's such a good moment from dad
you're trying to go back and dad's like
get there you've got this opportunity
that's great we need those those
influences yeah that last them that last
of the the next one Ronnie that we got
that we got up yeah that one so this so
then yes so this NASA hackathon happens
teach us about this yep so intertwined
so Minerva a lake before even coming to
Minerva like we had a very strong
Network between the seniors because our
first class is graduating in 2019 so
what happened is that like our seniors
had a very good space Club so very good
space lab where people were doing lots
of things and I definitely shout out to
enter nearfall start who was the Pioneer
over here and my friend a seer who
eventually helps me a lot in the process
into understanding how to come to
Minerva because he was the first one to
come here and eventually I got to
understand like would that this be a fit
and then I saw the traveling factor and
I really grew my love for traveling in
the gap here and that's why I took it
took this big step in coming to Minerva
so on 20th October of 2018 like we are
we as like about roughly 20 people go on
to NASA space apps Agathon which is
probably one of the biggest hackathons
or global hackathons that happen and in
the end we got to form a team like this
is my teammate from Minerva his name is
highteeeee um he has been one of the
most crucial parts of my growth at
Minerva and these are two two random
people we met in in NASA space of
hackathon and we did not even have a
team in the first day of the hackathon
so like his name is Kasia he's Ali so we
formed this team like in the first day
and I made an idea in about 15 minutes
thinking about how we can create a
virtual reality experience for students
or people around the world to feel like
an astronaut in Mars
so we use NASA's 3d database to create
space strophe which would help people
invest in specific places of mars right
so you're in a location where art is
inhabitable and now you are prompted to
go to like space and you are going to
have to go to different locations of
Mars
where you would find clues about which
places are good but I say Gale Crater is
a very good location for finding water
where you can create your likeness even
right so you're gonna invest 50 trove
tokens over there and you're going to
sustain your livelihood and you are
going to be able to treat among players
so creating a training scenario with a
virtual reality scavenger hunt mode was
our idea which eventually won the
californian rap and we were privileged
to be the global global nominee and
global champion from coming from from
minerva from california and broaden
Mountain View and San Francisco so that
was a breaking point where like the
first break coming into San Francisco
was NASA space apps which eventually led
me to taking further is and if you go to
the next slide we're gonna see like what
capability is that it in broaden so this
is a students on Capitol Hill
so students on Capitol Hill is a member
is a member organization of Alliance of
space development so Alliance of space
development deals with policy advocacy
regarding what we can do better for
space what we can do better for policy
advocacy in the Senate and the House of
Representatives in Washington DC of
United States like what you discovered
with your virtual reality experience can
awaken people to some very interesting
thoughts about the space economy and you
can then go and push that to senators
yeah very exciting so one thing that
happened is that I had seen my friends
going here but I was thinking about how
we can take this step further so I
applied I talked to Ian Burrell from
Virginia Tech about what they do over
here and I had the audacity that like no
other non-american had been in the best
of my knowledge been selected to be a
team leader before like anytime before
like because students on Capitol Hill
happened for three or four times before
and people were going on to talk to
senators who were elected by different
states it was very different because
back in our country we do not have that
capability to interact with our leaders
right we do not have that capability to
talk to people who are already in the
Parliament of a country because you have
to go through so many steps you have to
talk to his and assistant you have to
talk to the secondary assistant you have
to talk to the tertiary assistant and
even after that you're not going to be
able to get to the top leader but this
experience about directly going to a
senator and being able to tell
you tell them about your demands about
like this is what we want for speeds we
want a better safe space because
asteroids hit Russia in 2013 in
Chelyabinsk but we want a better system
from NASA so that the office of space
commerce can actually enact these laws
into the system so that we can have a
better space better better scenario
where people can go to Mars if they want
to so having to be the first
non-american to lead a team of veterans
going into Senate that was a crucial
opportunity in my life I had already
been to Mexico with my very good friend
Abraham and that gave me a wider
perspective into the global scenario of
how Chihuahua are like how the Mexican X
are like the border are going to a
Mexican wedding itself like all these
things and spending a new Christmas like
spending my first birthday in a
different country like these experiences
and one funny thing is that after this
the amount of love that I received like
I had the ability to meet two of my very
close relatives after five and a half
years I met my best friend from school
Shawn Palmer I also met my aunt one of
my closest aunts back in Virginia
Maryland and I had a journey over eight
cities of the United States so I went
over to fingers I went over to LA I went
over to Texas New Mexico I had my first
opportunity at skiing I went over to
Maryland I went over to Washington I
went over to Maryland all these places
like like and also into Mexico like
these places helped me see a broader
perspective that it's not just about the
congested phase of San Francisco because
at certain times no matter how inspiring
Silicon Valley is at a certain point it
feels very mechanic as to what you want
to do with your life right so having
this broader perspective as to having
that intuition about your business
abilities or your ideation abilities
this helped me push to go for more
forward so that was a crucial point in
me sustaining to see myself as someone
bigger even bigger with this flag in my
hand so I believe that like as a
Bangladeshi I aspire to be big and I'm
really thankful to Minerva schools and
the broader Bangladeshi community to
inspire me to a point where I could have
taken these risks
and you still push and you're pushing
with crossroads you're pushing with
about curious of the power of pause with
the students on Capitol Hill with taking
what's in your passions and breaking
through all of the barriers and getting
towards a place of greater success and
trying to help other people realize that
full potential within themselves as well
I love the mentor programs as well there
you're aiming to help inspire just
helping push down these opportunities
for more people and enable them to see
themselves and love themselves and push
for themselves and build a better social
fabrics very strong stuff
we wish you continued prosperity the
greatest prosperity city alright let's
do a couple just quick quick questions
on the way out and this is you tackling
your fears you're going skydiving what
is it tomorrow
no it's not tomorrow so like I'll soon
so two two big plans is that like I was
working with multiple startups in San
Francisco because Minerva gives us the
opportunity to interact with a lot of
civic partners in San Francisco so I
have the opportunity to work with live
guide for a month where we worked about
connecting mentors with students and
professional networks and develop them
in a way that they can be so big in and
understanding their potential second I
had this capability to work with Rachael
from Google where we work with emotional
intelligence and we create a system
where people can take a pause out of
their lives so like if you look into our
hand looking at that for 30 seconds and
zooming out to feel yourselves in the
moment into going forward like these are
the things that have been doing and even
though like there are lots of internship
applications that you can do and I have
had the utmost pleasure and gratitude
for finding those like I think like I
would still be wanting to go back to
Bangladesh to the to the audience who
are still with us today like finding are
finding a space where people who are
from an unprivileged background they can
find something so this image is a
representation of what what I'm
currently doing so I'm very afraid of
heights so like this is rappeling you're
on a single rope the Rope can tear down
anytime and if you fall you basically
die like it's not going back
so holding on to the trope and trying
out something new just because you want
to overcome that fear and you want to
feel limitless I love it is the point
where you have to you have to take the
break so like me height um and all the
friends that we have in Minerva we're
trying to do this thing on the 17th of
March which is a very special day like
we want to make a skydive from about
13,000 feet where we'd have a minute in
the air you're dealing with our fears
like basically dealing with our fears
good into like jumping into the unknown
so sure I think one big part of my day
is our big part of every day is waking
up feeling that like pressure like you
have that jaundice like everyday like
feeling that weakness like but from a
perspective of a survival scenario where
like you grow up with in toxicity you
grow up with in so many comments you
grew up with in like so many obstacles
coming to a point where you have
abundance coming to a point where you
are not sure you're all alone you have
never had the opportunity to make your
own food or go through such harsh
academics coming from gappiya comprising
all this with your work with your life
and keeping that balance in going going
to make a sustainable future I think
that required a lot of grit and coming
from a place where privilege was not a
very big word and fighting my way
through of just being just another
ordinary Bangladeshi kid I think that if
I have the capability do it you have the
capability to do it and biology students
have the capability to do it so I think
that is the biggest takeaway from my
life that I want to work with crossroads
I want to make education and higher
education accessible for most people
around the world so that education is
not a hit-or-miss opportunity but it's a
choice we want to make sure that people
have a choice in what they do in life
and I hope that through the inspiration
that I get from people like you and from
the people the opportunities that we
have in our hands we are able to create
a society or we are create able to
create opportunity for people where they
have the capability to come on and talk
about their lives and inspire people in
their journeys because my journey wasn't
like just hit it and everything goes in
I have been to a thousand debates I have
been to a hundred math Olympians I have
been to a thousand football games we
lost 90% to 95% of those things and only
five to five to three percent of the
things that we have won and we have
whole held onto that inspiration to take
the farthest going forward so I think
these are the things that make yourself
differentiated from our ordinary person
just going about what they can do in
their life and just passing their time
versus being someone who thinks of a
bigger dream a dream which doesn't allow
them to sleep and allows them to go
aspire and create opportunities for
people I think that finding happiness in
creating opportunities for people is the
current motivation that keeps me going
forward yes yes you speak about this
with great wisdom for your use and we
look forward to seeing you achieving
everything that you set out to do all
right quickly on the way out yeah this
is simulation so we must ask you are we
in a simulation I think we're in a
simulation and people like Alan have a
very big capability to highlight more
than 300 people who are aspiring in San
Francisco in Silicon Valley like he has
this capability of like drawing out
their stories so I would like to make a
comment about simulation if this were
the true things so my dream currently is
that with crossroads with the combined
help from my friends in militias Beyond
Borders or like in Bangladesh we would
like to create a system where millions
of youth from Bangladesh have the
capability to make a choice in their
education and playing a factor in that
and in order to create a more smooth
governance in order to create a more
smooth process of their life even by an
inch I think if that is something that I
can accomplish for myself I would
consider myself to be someone who has
done something for the people and I
would take that inspiration and go
forward and I would always strive to be
an inch better a degree better than what
I am today so I always try to keep
improving
so my
icon was Cristiano Ronaldo for a lot of
these because in 2012 he had worn bell
and ER and he had only one one one thing
in comparison to his arch rival like
Messi
five years down the line he told that in
his mind he was the best and that
stubbornness to believe in himself when
the entire world mocked him helped him
win four more volunteers to go on to 5 5
to level out the ark nominee it's not
about the competition the root of this
is no matter even if the world is
against you no matter if like billions
of people are against you if millions of
people say that you don't deserve it
like you have gone through it
and you were in a privileged scenario I
think you have a lot more in your story
I believe that you have so many
struggles that isn't described through
your smiles like Alan is smiling I'm
smiling we have so many struggles behind
our back we have so many Pierce's behind
our back but we choose to look into the
happier side that happiness project that
optimism part of this of our lives to
hold on to that and build upon that so I
think that building up would be my
simulation and that's where I would want
yourself do your getting through all of
the objectives of lay leveling up your
character in the game yes last question
is what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world I think the
most beautiful thing in the world is
unity like unity in people and peace I
believe because like happiness is
temporary and peace is permanent I
believe because peace helps people
sustain their lifestyle where away they
have a blank space like pieces like that
whiteboard that you can always wipe out
like no matter what the black dark marks
are on the piece of that whiteboard you
can always wipe that off and start from
a clean slate right because if you have
peace if you have unity within that
piece you're going to be able to do
anything that you want to just that you
would have to be spiritual to a degree
you have to have that meditation
capability and you'd have to have that
pause and taking a step back and looking
into your life as to see like what
capabilities that you
have and what opportunities that you are
going to have if you're just taking a
pause and looking into yourself it's not
about looking into what people are doing
it's not about the comparisons it's
about looking you at yourself and
looking at the best version of yourself
so looking at these two cells and seeing
how you can reach that person or you can
create a better society that's gonna
push you to a level which is far very
very very far ahead in comparison to a
person who you'd only care about
yourself so I think that portion that
thing is my take away for life like that
inspiration to do something bigger than
yourself my inspiration to see that like
piece can be the core of a lot of things
in life yes and with that piece in unity
we will have a much more prosperous
world
say yes here's my audience in Bangladesh
and I'd like to ask you one question is
that if you were to tell about like from
seeing me I am just a representation of
like the broader capabilities that my
country has I just wish you to sell
something to the audience who are like
currently in Bangladesh like what do you
want to tell them about this show about
me or like about yourself our
opportunities are just about dreams that
they might have just if you would want
to say a line or two
we its it can be absolutely random you
don't need to be very thoughtful just a
vice - well it's very important for me
to be thoughtful I it's very I don't I
don't treat anything frivolously so I
love that about you yeah I love that
yeah so something that that inspires a
sense of divine collective unity and
potential on our planet is to really get
the big history divine perspective of
why we're here everyone and when we
think about all things ever evolving
evolving just on this rock on this earth
it can help us better realize that we
are all one we are all together and we
have to figure out how to best prosper
collectively and there's people around
the world that care about really
figuring that out and a lot of this
conversation has been about that and
that's why I really wanted to sit down
with you on the show so the one the one
thing is remember that sense of unity
that sense of togetherness that we have
and and let's do our best to make an
opportunities available for everyone to
be their full creative potential on this
world and really figuring that out so
that would be the thing and I want to
thank you so much for coming on thank
nor is you it was a privilege for me to
come here and sharing with you thank you
thank you so much Sheldon and it's been
a pleasure to be here it's been a
pleasure to sharing my story and
learning a bit more about the takes that
you have and this amazing platform
called simulation series please
subscribe to it I hope and I say that
like I would want us to believe in
ourselves in Bangladesh I'd like the
world to believe in themselves and just
give their part of the part they're
they're part of the puzzle to the entire
big story right so I think if we have
that commitment within ourselves if we
have people like Alan working if we have
people like this these people or unless
we're working right now I
it's highly possible for us to achieve
anything that we deem impossible right
now because impossible isn't a word it's
just a state of mind possibility love it
love it love it so so so so thanks
everyone for tuning in from Bangladesh
we greatly appreciate you and all the
friends around the world thank you so
much for tuning in
also I want to thank you guys as well
for tuning and greatly appreciated thank
you we would love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below on the episode we
would also love you to continue
supporting artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in help us succeed in
our communities help build a better
social fabric around us everyone thank
you
- Ron Vargas for producing and directing
a very much Ronnie and go and build the
future everyone go and manifest your
dreams and to be the simulation the
simulation that you want to see in the
people leveling up a rematch love and
take care we'll see soon is it thank you
so much guys for hosting
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect
[Music]